this is a production of Cornell
University
okay my name is Nina basket I know most
of you a few years and I'm the faculty
member of permanent horticultural work
in the field of urban horticulture which
I thought before we get into this study
I'd like to just give you a little
perspective and we're this study fits
into a larger whole my knowledge I've
been here over 31 years so there's a bit
of a history of kind of degree research
I've been doing and and this is a
logical outcome of some of the things
when you were down so I'm just going to
give you a little bit of a brief
background and gold launch into this
study on ground penetrating radar so
research that I work on primarily
dealing with laska urban landscape
establishment for most of that time it
really means urban tree establishment
street trees and the most difficult
types of sites that you might consider
and so everything I do fits into four
different areas first trying to
understand the side constraints the
abiotic side constraints and and
opportunities that might exist on the
site in terms of soil compaction limited
soil volume for drainage I PA all the
different things that you might consider
my be there and and are there and then
try to make good flat selections for
those difficult site conditions matching
the plant to the site conditions very
often we find that the sites can be so
limiting that we have to do some sight
modification we have to do which month
basically is talking about small
modification we have to do to an able to
use to grow at all achieve their
functional abilities in the urban
environment and then finally
transplanting a lot can happen between
getting the tree in the nursery and then
getting to the site and the first couple
of years after transplanting so this
whole kind of four step process is where
my research compasses and of course some
of these things talking so that if you
have a better site you can have more
class selection you have a porcine years
plant selection palette to be more
limited so what I'm going to be speaking
today today mostly is about some of the
issues inside modification and how we
look at roots in difficult sites so some
of the work we started doing in the
early 1990s was looking at how much soil
you need what our roots grow in very
difficult sites like this cave sites
what you might have four by five
openings in the street and that tree is
going to go in there and we're going to
hope for the best but these trees don't
live very long sometimes they do and not
sure why so we tried to look at some of
these most difficult downtown urban
sites to see what's going on and part of
the issues that sure you can the small
opening but their soil over there but
what you may not know is that when you
have to delay payment on soil you have
the purpose of compacted soil first so
it's load there so the pavement won't
subside or shift or fail so this is just
example of the purposeful compaction
that happens to soil under paper
anything and then you can see here what
happened here is a tree area this is
reinforced with this comp we going to go
over and talk and there's really nothing
that's different about this versus this
so we have a very restricted routing
situation and trees respond to that and
here I say the tree is being lowered
into the coffin that's maybe the extent
of the useful soil that the tree has to
grow it so it's not surprising that
these trees language they don't grow
very well died early and it's examples
of them if you start looking around and
you see the nature of compacted soils
and compacted root zones tree goes over
it's always a great opportunity to look
at where the roots are you know that
roots are fairly shallow within the top
meter of the soil even less when you get
into urban situations where there's so
much more compassion and they use our
handy-dandy air excavation tool this is
air space we used to uncover roots
because we've been looking to see about
blue growth in urban environments for
many years and it's been very difficult
study if any of you very tried to
measure roots in normal soil you notes
that now we're dealing with soil roots
under pavement and it's really good but
sometimes we've been able to take up the
compy years a tree lawn where some
pretty big trees and you see where the
roots grow underneath that four inches
of concrete talk about a meters depth of
rooms but we'd like to have a meters
typically these roots grow very very
superficially no four issues five inches
and then they're making it away to
somebody's front yard and the trees
might get what it needs there's no way
the tree really could survive in this
small strip so it makes its way
two surveys front yard and gets them the
volume that it needs and so we look we
spent many years picking out how much
soil you need to support a tree to allow
to give to its envisioned design size
when you plant a tree you have
envisioned design size and functions
that go along with that and so we it's a
work in the mid 1990s early 1990s coming
up with models that figured out how much
do you need in this location with this
precipitation we're just wormhole in the
past in the soil and this size tree and
I'm going to go into this but we have
some models that are pretty good
approximations which we hope to get
better at modeling the amount of soil
needed to grow a tree to what your
vision so one of the things we need knew
we needed to do was find more volume
safely we need to find more volume under
these paper areas parking lot sidewalks
and we develop something called see with
structural soil or structural soil which
is the sexual Maya further back it's now
15 years old is a patented material at
Cornell pattinson me is now over 1,200
installations all around the country and
Canada Europe and so on so it basically
would amounts to is this is crushed
stone about one inch diameter and we use
a proportion of stone to soil so that
the stone is touching stone so that if
you put a compactive effort on this push
down on it the stone is going to create
a rigid lass a rigid skeleton but you
can have large pore sizes because of the
one size stone and if you fill those
pores with soil and basically meet the
engineers problems in terms of having
compassion but still allow true lose to
go through this soil see the concept
fans
soil Richard Gladys with soil in the
pores oops kind of shoot through this
thing like Swiss cheese so we've been
working on this for many years and this
is the way we use it in sidewalk
situation where here's our curve in your
street you might have an opening where
the tree goes but underneath that side
walk into the building face we could
have a lot of volume found by Lucic
structural sort you wouldn't see it in
fact and Epico is the structural small
capital world there's more structural
soil underground what you never see but
than anywhere else although the state
would have the most numerous structural
saw installations as California so 1997
with this long meadow street here the
road was narrowed as it became one way
and this whole strip here is structural
soil being put in and men trees when and
after that that's what the way here so
you can see these days of campus trees
growing in structural soil with porous
paving basically just block paving
enabling those trees to grow where
otherwise it would be pretty difficult
situation and there's all over town so
now let's get to a study so looking at
developing all this work in terms of
structural soil and where roots grow and
finding enough volume we really wanted
to see where the roots were growing to
see how successful we've been in terms
of the tree growth we can measure the
tops of the trees but we really wanted
to see what was happening below ground
so in 2003 we put in this blue glass
lane we put in these sweet cosine loves
to know where where we dug down a better
me
I took the soil out and we had some
strips which were compacted put this
little back in and compacted it it lifts
so layers so will be similar to what you
see in a compact extreme environment we
lined it with very heavy no plastic so
hopefully with contain the soil and the
roots we have six trenches like this
which we've dug some of them had just
compacted silt loam compacted to a very
high engineering level which will be for
so long about 1.8 which would be
exceptionally difficult basically
prevent room penetration and social soil
is also put in some of these trenches
also compacted to the engineering
standard which is actually higher about
197 almost two point O volka city and
get the tree roots can really access
this even though it is so compacted
because of that dual major stone to sort
so you're Jeff basically packing the
soil so that we would have different
trenches of different soil types and we
put a base layer of stone on top of
everything this is not structural so
this is just the base layer stone which
we put under concrete anyway just to
increase the drainage and then we paid
the whole thing and within these
openings here we have clonal well at
least the scions are ponal to the extra
platanoides emerald queen to plant in
2003 just lightly branch whips the signs
are phone Allah granted
Rousseff's fast forward 2008 trees are
growing differently these are going
differently in different soils which is
what we expected here is a package soil
except that's not so bad but compare
that to structural soil one right next
to it it's different ok so we're
measuring root growth we have this
long-term study so we can manipulate
look at things as they occur in these
different plantings there so when it
came back that same time I went to a
trade show as part of the international
society of our horticulture and I saw
this person talking about tree root root
radar radar that you could actually find
roots locate roots underground in the
soil or under pavement and I was like my
eyes this knife is amazing you know I'm
so I'm talking to him I said yeah I
would love to test your material and see
if it would work and you know really
what we're looking for great tool and it
took a while but we decided to go study
where we actually do a ground truth in
other words you are radar on radar on
these very uniform trees on the thule
force all times and then do a total
excavation of those root systems to see
that what we saw actually was with the
radar saw or how close they were how
good was in other words i saw the pretty
pictures at the booth but i was I wanted
to see myself but this was actually
going to work because that's expensive
toy and nope
so this is our souped-up tricycle down
kind of training radar machine it is
that's the guts of it thirty-five
thousand dollar tricycle so it's nothing
that I own so out of work with an
arborist who is well very well versed
and using this goes all around the
country locating different things on the
ground for various people and especially
roots especially groups where they might
be impacting utilities or construction
experience name is Gary Rafael from
dynamic Theresa so this is how basically
the works you got your goals you've got
your radar electromagnetic waves or
transmitting to the ground use the green
bars here waves if you like and when it
comes in contact with some object those
waves will be reflected or refracted
back in a predictable way it's basically
the idea behind it and it can go over
ground or over pavement and then you get
a basically a virtual trench here is the
length and this is death and these X's
represent detected roots okay so the
important thing is why how can we get to
tech roots here is called it's called a
dielectric this is just something that
needs to be explained for a minute so
when you have the electromagnetic waves
coming down into this any kind of
situation the object the soil or roots
will have something called dimension is
a dimensionless ball be called the
dielectric which is how that material
responds in the electric field so
obviously metals and things with high
conductivity will respond very rapidly
but all materials respond to some level
and a bit of the difference between two
objects within an area that will give a
high dielectric which gives you better
radar response so to make it clear where
groups which are basically water right
the dielectric of water is 81 and the
dielectric of typical soils is 13 so
that's a high difference between water
and typical soils and we actually this
has to be calibrated in the field we do
this and so when you have a high
difference between one type of object
and another of a high dielectric and you
can get a good radar response that is
the general idea what would work so here
we are at our field again and so we had
basically this is a measure of 24
inches between the wheels and we went up
one side of the pad and another side of
the pad and then we did lines across so
we would go up here go here and then
move on cause we get a virtual trench on
a route detection from the machine and
now you see on top by the way I didn't
take a picture that there's a screen so
you actually can see while you're
walking and is measuring that you can
see you can detect routes although
that's not the data that comes out it's
just an idea that something is there and
what you see is a parabola when you see
a room basically you see this nice
parabola that say oh I've got something
there and you can but then the software
basically source these things out cut it
out so we did this and we can do it in
different depth ranges these trenches
were meter deep but what you see here is
four inches to 14 inches deep and you
still have these marks are just marking
where the tree with us and so this there
are no root such as one room here in
that 6.42 13 18 inch range for these
different pads trees but then we get
into the 13 almost 14 to 21 inch range
you all those all these green squid
crosses are detected roots and then we
go deeper 22 inches to 29 inches these
rep
moves in the deeper layers of these
trenches so I can put it all together it
was very very hard and this is basically
the whole longer routes in those areas
okay so here's a tree this pink box that
where the tree is year of course we
couldn't go right on top of the tree but
around retreating in these pads which we
had restricted because it was heavy no
plastic we can be assured that's where
the roots were and so what it looks like
if you do the virtual trench and here at
study at 12 39 feet and you can see
basically the roots here's these lines
represent trees ok Larry tree centers ok
so you're going along and after the data
is worth we have these are the roots
there i found this tree this tree so
they look pretty good I mean we were
quite excited about this but it still
had to be ground truth so now this is
the fun part so we had to actually
excavate these trees in such a way that
we keep them in the same orientation to
then check whether the GPR correspondent
do what I saw with my eyes so we have
these these pads or six by six trees
inside and we had our base course event
are so this is what we did JC on the
back whole year to book pads and then
excavate it around took all the plastic
so that we could use our airspace to
excavate the root system there's easy
bruising structure soil is for
structural so it looks like okay once I
stone was going through it side of the
trench and then with our airspace we
cleaned off the entire root system of
ten trees five in structural soil and
five and biscuit packet solo with the
airspace so that we remove the whole new
system in one piece we try a few things
before we strike taking squadrons and
Justin able to keep everything you know
where the roots were in space so we
decided to clean off the whole system
like one piece which was them to several
hours to do this but it's nice
pressurized air that allows us to do
this kind of work and this is absolutely
so that was a tree growing in structural
soil exceeding this is extra five notice
nor we make all very fibrous root system
this is five years ago and so here we
have our tree in the compacted so long
you can see the massive structure here
we've impacted there's a tree growing
with some weeds on top and the root
system basically never made it into that
compacted so long where it did get out
is that sometimes it's found the edge of
that
it's way down the edge but this is what
the trees look like in that compact is
so long very easy to miss to 20 minutes
you know one would took several hours
but that's a typical system so comparing
two together the differences in growth
we see our corresponding someone to the
difference in the root growth system so
we had ground-penetrating radar looking
at these rooms and these are the five of
each in these so now thing about
ground-penetrating radar it does not
really see very small diameter roots
basically the work has been done with it
says it has to be basically a centimeter
or bigger in diameter so I got these
roots up in the house and i poisoned
them up and I had to now skeletonize
them take off all those fine roots so
that I only be left with roots of one
centimeter diameter or bigger which I
then could put on a template measure and
the same orientation it had been in the
field and then get my count to socially
so this is a little bit work as well and
so again I skeletonizing them to find
out only basically the larger roots and
you can see the structural soil and
sometimes it looks actually encapsulate
the stone
see how we go through this medium and
then I had you know a template of the
opening of the way the tree troll
planted and I would put the tree they
are the same orientation at middlefield
and count groups outside of the opening
missed a lot in the middle but I had a
lot but that's what not what we're
measuring we're measuring those outside
sort of hard to see here should have
painted a white but it was really those
roots outside that we were measuring the
ground penetrating radar so this is what
I would come is exotic to the graph
table several tree roasted ground
penetrating radar here's three number 63
and so we throw it into quadrants eight
quadrants around each tree so here's the
number of routes to and find why we have
two counts in the corners is because we
had the longitudinal scans and we have a
horizontal traffic as well we had two
counts with corners where our skins
overlap but here are eight quadrants
around this tree and if you look this
represents my visual and we had two
different people doing this so someone
was doing
this and I was counting this so we were
founding trying to make things better
than [ __ ] so here's three member 63
again at 292 two four five four five six
six
and 10 so it was looking pretty good I
mean it wasn't exactly looking pretty
good and so we had to take all this data
and make some statistical sense order
and this is one way we started to look
at it so it had the radar counts and the
visual counsel if they were no
difference between them it will be at
zero this is a nice little bell curve
was just GPR and structural soil we take
our visual count excavated count we
subtract the GPR and if it was bigger
than the excavator can we get a miner's
number so we have if I had four routes
that I saw and the GPRS edris five
routes hit me minus one which means the
GPR overestimated by one route okay
likewise Oscar range you know I said for
the GPRS of three then we have one extra
so it would underestimate but you can
see that it's simply nice curve we were
pretty happy with this that it seemed to
not go too far field we had a couple of
threes or fours that were that much
different than my visual scan but this
was looking good when the compact is so
long the GPR overestimated where they go
coincided exactly 4 verse 24 words but
the GPR overestimated which means that
was bigger than my visual considerably
always wasn't that many rooms but it was
simply overestimating in that massive
soil structure so this is interesting we
thought about how we could what was
doing this we did some regressions so he
had five trees was eight quadrants
around each tree so we had 40 counts now
this is not 40 because there's some oh
das that are actually overlap but this
represents the 40 counts for this is
structural soil radar count versus
excavated so they're in a perfect world
and we want to want but we have
basically the R squared which point 86
for this and we have ninety five percent
so we think this is a pretty good
estimate of reasonable agreement between
GPR and visual now with the soil
compacted soil versus the visual our R
squared is this point 71 not as good as
the social soil and we also saw him
we're not locally data that GPR was over
estimating slightly so and we also
basically we still have a significant
regression is still significantly
finding those roots by GPR and those
correspond to the visual we think what's
happening in those massive soil
structures is that we get very few of
those big no nice boots that we found in
structural store they were over a
centimeter apart we found lots of very
fine roots but most of those will take
it off during the process of
skeletonized so what we think might be
happening with
look at is that when you get lots of
very fine roots together and kind of jam
together the radar is probably sitting
that as a rude as opposed to just one
fine ruled out in the soil when you get
lots of s roots together and I was
taking them off in the skeletonizing
process and I probably in that sense
actually took off what GPU / see who
have to test this but it's a i think a
reasonable way to thinking about and
it's another research showing that in
massive structures of massive soil
structure don't get as good agreement
between so we thought winds are pretty
good so we wrote basically based on this
work which is by the papers been except
this window we didn't print a couple
months from now but we think we have
enough information to say i'm going to
get a pretty good approximation of where
the roots are under pavement by using
this and i don't have to ground truth
everything and yeah i'm going to be
especially in structural soil or soil
and have lots of course that have good
agreement with the GPR and the actual
account so we want to start using this
to see where the roots live so we're
actually started using this already in
different situations here you see a
typical problem of trees growing in very
small opening the sidewalk and a very
serious problem log so i'd welcome
people which you know it's not so much
the problem for the tree is a problem
for musicality someone trips and falls
and there was a really know about suit I
mean this is amazing the amount of
expensive for personalities to deal with
liability
people tripping a ball that's the United
States by the way I want you know in
Holland where they have a different type
of structure soil they don't compact so
much have great bumpy sidewalks in
Amsterdam and if someone tripped and
fell you just saying you gotta walk more
carefully mr. burns going to be more
careful next time but this is the other
season so in some places it's millions
and millions of dollars spent on this so
one of the things we wanted to do was to
look at the possibility of creating
break out sometimes places for routes to
safely go under our sidewalk and access
somebody's front yard or some other open
bowling soil and on State Street we have
some very narrow tree laws going down
into 2004 we planted some tonal elm
trees there we created breakout zones
taking out two squares of concrete four
inches that excavating down 24 inches
put structural soil in and then repaid
tree so we're going to try to do is get
these roots go under and into this
person's front yard without even the
sidewalk as without making them so
shallow and some recent research just
done that's just email the Journal of
our culture shows that they definitely
if you have a room that's down deeper if
your sidewalk is here here's a root and
as that room expands radially to the
point you can that force will be
dissipated
over a much larger area than if you have
a room right under the sun block and so
that's what we're trying to do is get
the roots deep so that if there's any
movement the whole sidewalk will move as
one and not crack so here's a state
street and our tree launders our tree
and we did some scans here they break
out zones 1 2 3 forward in the lawn this
was to see that this was 2009 I to see
if their roots that got here he also did
one skin five we started in the normal
soil and then they intersected the
structural store then after the normal
sort of see where the roots were we had
a control tree on the side which was
planted same time but there was no good
babe just treaty in the normal situation
so this is some interesting thing in the
world the other thing that's really
interesting about this I can continue to
do this again and again and again over
time and see what's happening without
disturbing roots so that's a real
benefit of using this was obviously even
when we had our airspeed we're doing all
kinds of great brute excavation that was
it you could really sort of put it all
back so this is great so there's Gary
would be tricycle scanning over the
break out so on the sidewalk there's our
minor role accolade elm it's totally
clonal material and here's our trench
this is interesting this is scan find
where this is start of the breakouts are
you
this is in normal soil without any
structural soil so you've got a couple
of very superficial roots then when you
hit the breakout zone and get all this
proliferation of roofs down quite deep
too this must be at least 24 inches 26
inches and then when you mad at radegast
own goose start to go superficial again
this is a control tree on the other side
of street where basically you have not
only very few roots but they're
typically more of a surface so we have
to look at this over time to see if we
really know he gets down there we also
have roots of the surface so what's
going to happen in terms of sine walk
eating is this going to make a
difference in terms of the long-term
help the tree and also integrity for
sidewalk just what it looks like for a
plan view here's our tree scandal on
gears here's a breakout zone this is the
grass okay so here so we sort of
here's our control tree all over the
surface this is lower middle level of
roots very few roots in a middle level
and the deep level of risk we had
nothing in the control here quite a lot
in the structural saw so rule school to
the entire death of structural sort it's
engineered to be porous enough yet have
enough water holding capacity to allow
it to really shoot through so
unfortunate name see you social soil
roots / + where foot 4.7 this would
please no rinds 4.26 who's the best
grass roots were already into the grass
2.3 roosters were put in in our skin
side but we started before the break out
so we had you know basically point nine
roots per square foot hit the same skin
when I hit the structural soil
preparation of roots and our control we
had right on top of the weather was four
groups so you know it's not surprised
that rooms grow well in social soil
we've known that's a long time but we're
looking to see whether we can engineer
these
tuitions where lose can find more vile
safely without eating a cycle so i'll
show you could call there really quick
examples of what we've been using fact
he's in places you know this is green
star parking lot right the train comes
through twice a day always a rush hour
and we planted in 1997 we planted
pyramidal black locust because the train
would prune them away to another so do
we just dreamy very now and nineteen
ninety-seven you see where Neil is sunny
different color we took off the asphalt
15 feet wide 60 feet long parallel to
the tracks before that the trees we went
down and push structural soil in 30 feet
deep 30 inches deep sorry that a whole
area compacted it then relayed the
basketball we left about an 18 inch
opening there right next to the tracks
and 1997's when we planted the trees
they're still there quite a bit bigger
than thing this picture shows but we had
a conference here couple years ago where
we were talking to the folks about
structural soil and we decided to let's
go look see if the room so where we
think they are under under the [ __ ]
here so we actually tore up some of this
[ __ ] and actually on top of the
normal face structural soils
we also did a ground-penetrating radar
to see could we see any difference in
the growth in one area versus the other
so this is the scans and we did over
some scans 10 11 12 14 we're in trouble
soil 13 and 15 or in the typical face
course right so they were not then we
actually opened up the sidewalk here as
you can see the extent of structural
soil and see what their moves quite all
over the place here structural then we
get to our typical base it's very very
few routes so what found with so that
was pretty so what we found would
contain radars here skin 12-14 this was
filmed in clay right out here the tree
here's
Mike deep for that particular tree and
this is the scans 13 and 15 which were
beyond where we know structural soil and
this was there were a few roots but very
shallow and not very many roots in the
area adjacent to instruction soil
question is how far they go this is
giving us more information that this was
a very useful technique especially when
we see names the last example will show
you is a project we're still working on
this is in Brooklyn New York is a big
part called mclaren park this is just a
track factor people use in the park and
in 1998 35 trees along lorimer street
and driggs and we spent all this area to
see
we put social soil into so this is three
years is that this area to the park the
structure soil went about seven feet the
entire list had a way to the deep wall
as here so the Jesuses three different
species here years 11 years so these are
big trees now so we have Gary they're
doing skin alone this to see how much
root growth we have have deep now is
interesting we really city the only
putting 24 inches which is our minimum
depth for structural soil but as we
going through 35 trees looking at we can
actually tell the difference between
structural soil normal slow because the
structural soil has a different
dielectric it's nine regular slowest
protein we can see a difference on scan
and one point someone the contractor
basically extended on structural soil of
north mackay so we got place would we
didn't put in 24 inches we saw put in
whatever 9 inches in any way back over
the contractor was so we're now looking
at one foot half of the fiber from the
tree and we've got tremendous amount of
they had to go through to actually
figure out how much how much all these
different scans were getting in the
sidewalk there
being able to support pretty good tree
grow their training all the research
into triangle appliances way beyond the
time we could separate the roots so they
are massively but we're still working on
this data set up just so conclusions
grounds which guys appear to run rate
gbr counsel and move depth and best
accuracy a pic of the root the more
accurate the higher the wider that
parabola is on the screen that I see
trevose with a full deck of some sort of
soil is very useful non-destructive and
you know what I'm really excited about
is I've go over it again like a sample
it last year sample in two years and see
where things have changed what's the
root depth how far they expanded that's
a really beneficial thing without
destroying roots and what we're very
excited about is a to revisit our model
of slow volume needed to support a tree
and now with GPR we could actually see
where the roots arts that are modeling
where we think they are we can actually
empirically determine where roots are
and how much soil vine they are
colonizing and correlate that with tree
growth and to see if we need to change
or tweak our model to make it more
accurate in terms of not allowing
massive architects contractors and what
emotions to say if you want to go
through this size you need to have this
amount of soil volume in this area
in this area with the semantic
precipitation if you want to allow their
tree to get beside you can't put it a
four by five box and expect it to get to
what you envisioned so we hope to come
up with design guidelines and determined
upon us all necessary to support trees
in different parts of the country gear
to different precipitation so we've been
working on this and this is something
we'll be working on in the next few
years so we're very excited about this
work also just the last slide is that
they're always these places that you
know how is this tree a lot all these
places that you know I would I say well
you really need to give up three a lot
of soil will have to go to design size
and this one always point to this hold
up there's that tree it's got nothing
you know I'm a 3 by 2 opening and why
he's going fine and it is going fine I
suppose is the hot dog water that gets
put in the air I don't know what but now
another thing I'm going to be doing tom
with all of our meal and working on
looking at tree response to different
soil square areas basically work what
appears to be the Isola volume and you
have trees that are in narrow spaces of
purely moderate spaces and like in parks
and in general trees that appear to be
in smaller spaces or growing less well
but they're always some outliers that
are going when appears to be narrow
spaces are growing really well now we
hope to do
take the GPR I see where are the roots
are they in someone's basement are they
in the sewer are they in the baby no
there's you know we can actually find
that I supposed to say well maybe
tenders sewer system here and it's in a
sewer system good luck coat it's going
to be having all it needs four years ago
I don't want it up was standing so we're
going to be looking at some of these
just places where we can't understand
how it trees alive I hope that when we
see where the roots are it'll give us
more insight into what allows some of
these trees to grow that shouldn't be
grow so that's basically the story where
we are now we're going to be using this
my fellow authors Jason boo boskie from
Rutgers Gary Rafael from only souped-up
tricycle so instead of buying one he has
all the software and experience I just
by his services he's just love to work
with us and tony was already from this
naval academy and tree radar Inc he
developed this whole tree radar system
so
Nina you didn't mention how the radar
system reacts to stones or other mineral
elements in the soil well it reacts to
everything has a dielectric everything
has reactivity or conductivity and so
one of the things when you're working
you basically calibrate the machine with
some known we put some rebar in exactly
certain depth swegen Excalibur English
machine and soil is well known as a
dielectric of 13 but structural soil we
found we first did the scan it just
didn't seem right that the depth were
not right and so we then we calibrated
it has a PS dielectric enough so we had
to figure this out these are homogeneous
soil so when you have a lot of jump in
the soil you see that what you see
utilities you see stone is really not
very conductive so you don't wanna see
that like to see some waviness the
pattern but those things that have
and there's a whole lot more in terms of
the guts of this machine and how it
works I am going to try to explain yeah
I seem to get a sort of a yes or no
answer you don't get any information
about loop diameter no you don't you
don't picks it up or it doesn't pick it
up something when I look on the screen
which is not the bestest [ __ ] raw data
sometimes they are really strong but you
see what when you see a really strong
four hours in whoa that's a big room but
it also might be here crossing the road
perpendicular sometimes what up here you
know you're wrong side of route so
you're not going to get the same strong
signal we can also we've also done them
centric rings around trees and there's
new software which is an able to
actually give a connect the dots instead
of just having points it's just
connected doesn't give you areas of
probability of roots yes their roots
there but here's an area we have greater
probability so we'll be working with
this new software that actually gives
you more of our roots can virtual stamps
that have just the cross doesn't
so kind of following up with that what
about functionalities if you could
actually have roots there but they are
servicing a tree in any well what's
interesting is if the roots are done you
won't get a good signal I mean because
once the water is a syn water it's a so
you could actually look at turnover over
time that's really have a thought about
I'm thinking about doing this iterative
study we go back again that again but
when your roots die
puffer for load is that the tree roots
of going along are they intercepting the
root cellar hands on the soil but are
they all soil both mentally I mean we
don't see grass roots at all aggression
to just put are they towards the surface
where they're competing with the church
they can be right at the surface maybe
depending on the boat that's named as a
texture slow give us it can be right up
at the surface and do you think that
they would be good at intercepting
nitrogen losses from sure I'm sure
they'd be good maybe functional I don't
know how in terms of competition that's
what you're stuck yeah I just thought I
just looking at your photos and they
looked really nice to be able to
quantify lawns that we have that system
where your training the roots to go
under the pain
come on are they effective at at
minimizing nitrogen losses from the
urban systems that would be a nice way
to look at it potential unfortunately
for those of you who work with
vegetables of asia's plants so I said
what do you plan people are going to
make out apples grapes any woody plant
get a go get a reasonable size root and
then in fact I remember a couple years
ago when we had the air spade the tool
was I went out to free bill this one
want to look at broccoli uncover the
roots of Robin you got this thing with
huge compressor behind it turn this
thing on the rocks it took that brought
me right out the heirs I don't think it
was what can't stay on or off so yeah
the example you gave about the green
star parking lot how much do you
attribute that change in root growth
from the structural soil to the other
soil to the roots doing better
instruction sort of verses there's just
simply a transition and you know that
roots don't like to leave formica
transition but what happens in papers
that you have a purposeful compaction so
it's not just sort it's highly compacted
soil
specifications and we put the structural
soil and you can still compact at the
engineering specifications but because
it creates that [ __ ] ladders goals
before that so it's not just soil it's
really compacted you don't expect to
have anything below four to six inches
there's a need to crack or they didn't
compact about you have poor construction
what
I haven't done exactly that restore me
has been going into different oils me
but we have 15 years of research showing
that structural soilwork's that wasn't
really the purpose of this is really
looking at so we have interests you know
keep on looking at social swollen but
often Norway maples are given bad rap
but most the times norm it will make up
the tree population in Northeast in new
york state minimum thirty percent fifty
percent so you have many many more trees
at one time which you know the make up
fifty percent they don't be more of the
trees on either side walk also the fact
that you have highly compacted sub
grades we call it under the sidewalk is
going to push all the roots surface but
she saw that tree them had painted white
really at the surface so it really has a
lot more to do with the faculty
compacted soils to main engineering
specifications and that pushes roots up
to the surface doesn't matter though be
so we actually caused the problem by the
way we construct sidewalks in liquid
these situations are they are they if
they break out of their strict an area
they occupy the interface between us
concrete and the base course if the four
inches of concrete and then there's a
area an interface where you get some
precipitant get some water basically
forming on the bottom of the concrete
and humans can take advantage of that
that's what I see what's when they're on
your sidewalk they go right under the
concrete it's an interface little
freestar is getting get up held in and
they make it there they don't go down
deep if they can't put the book that's a
process such that they cannot be so
maybe there's a little bit terms of
species your solar maples knowing maples
those that are typically tolerated
wetter soils and have a shallow root
system but the shower do you think has
more to do with soil that has to do with
stitches when you have a situation i can
picture that how does not for to get to
the rest yeah
we've got all kinds of sewers guys put
in the water house into the tree every
day and just sits under the tree water
moves laterally I mean enough practice
of the surface to get any walking I mean
there's a lot that's really
counterintuitive to this thing and be
alive yeah and that's why we want to see
where the roots office maybe they are in
some kind of pipe where you're getting
something we can't see and this is a lot
of interest in
sorry boys okay um it would also appear
to me that if you're in a street tree
type situation where is confined type of
space where we know that routes will
even sort of go down and come back up
and do all kinds of funky Grove can you
account for that somehow basically not
being able to count a route twice or
three times or four times someone goes
back I mean yeah when they're stuck in
this box I would imagine they don't have
a lot you know they don't do the normal
sort of outward distribution I think
Lisa sleek off these at the time we're
actually now picking out each tree
between each tree so we're reducing the
competition whether we do
ground-penetrating radar same place
again i'm not sure but i think we were
in a situation five years growth they're
still it's not outward hound we didn't
see anyone when we actually with the
roads that they would end worse
everything was going
you showed one photo of course baby is
that becoming more common in the urban
landscape why don't we have more well I
showed a picture blah blah favor which
is not morderd that's porous but we have
porous asphalt and that's a whole nother
talk another time we are growing trees
in porous asphalt in parking lots of
structural soil underneath and we're
actually now seeing the fact that the
trees in the porous asphalt and we have
trees and traditional asphalt actually
growing better than those in traditional
so there is some and also there's water
recharge into the ground which is the
other good we have a parking lot
thanks everybody this has been a
production of Cornell University on the
web at cornell.edu